hello and welcome to episode four of
buying and selling in freeto playay
RuneScape so in today's episode we are
going to try some of the more expensive
pieces of the trimmed armor like we
might do the iron set which is at least
100K pretty much for any piece we might
try trimmed black armor which is also
very expensive and we might try a couple
new items again we're going to try to
keep this episode a bit shorter cuz I
don't know my attention span isn't
really anything past five or six minutes
I don't know why I'm making 15-minute
videos um so yeah I'm just going to try
and make it a bit shorter maybe release
a few more another reason is cuz we made
absolute bank is that how you say it
yeah okay in this episode so we didn't
it didn't really need to be that long or
else we'd almost be done okay so we're
just going to jump right into it here
we're going to start with the team Cape
7 uh which we've already checked the
margin for it was pretty good we're
going to try buying them for 45 GP each
now 2,000 it's probably a little
ambitious here we're not going to get
that many but who knows so and the
second item we thought about doing the
adant plate legs and we ended up
checking the margin wasn't really worth
it uh so we ended up going with was the
uh mithil full Helm G I believe yeah so
the mythal full Helm G uh we're just
going to check the margin on her own um
apparently it's more expensive than that
so yeah it's I think it was about 30k
people were selling it for and we were
able to buy it for somewhere around 20K
I believe uh so 10K margin on here I'm
just going to check here yep so 29 and
40 GP people are selling it for and we
would be able to buy it for
approximately
17,46 to so that's a that's a 13k margin
12K margin so that's pretty
good and for our last item here we're
going to go with another team Cape uh
we're going to try to team Cape three so
we're just checking it again it has 500
and
51 so yeah that's a great margin on that
uh probably won't get 450 GP each on
these but uh we can see how many we can
buy for the 55 price so we have put
another 2K in and yeah we'll see how
this
goes all right we just made so much
money so let's just check what happened
here the team Cape sevs we managed to
buy 186 of them and each one we bought
made about 500 GP on so that alone we
bought all the team capes for8 1,300 and
we sold them for 102k so that's like 90k
we made on the team C sevens the mithil
full Helms we're making about 11,000
each one we bought and we bought 26 so
we bought them all for
558k and we sold them for
767k which is
210k profit and the team cap 3's we
bought uh 90 of them approximately let's
see 93 and we bought them all for 5K and
we sold them for 37k so that's another
like 30k right there so we in total we
made like 3 400k just off those three
flips okay so we're going to see if we
can uh repeat that again here so we're
going to come up with a couple new items
um we're not going to end up doing the
black plate legs te uh we're probably
going to end up doing the more expensive
plate body uh but for the first item we
are just dumping the uh full Helms we
had from earlier we're going to sell
them for about 25k you can kind of see
in the background there just the six
that we had left yeah
25500 um and for the second item we are
just going to do another team Cape again
surprise surprise we're going to do the
team cave 9 this time which I think had
the 30400 uh GP margin on it yeah so 400
uh we could sell it for and buy it for
90 okay so yeah that's a good margin
we're going to try that and uh lastly
here we're going to try the black plate
body G uh which kind of buys and sells
anywhere between 150 and 200k I checked
online League of Legends go
away um yeah so we're going to try to
put in kind of the lowest offer possible
to about 150k for the black plate bodies
and we'll only be able to afford a
couple of them so we're going to buy I
think three or four yeah so hopefully
that works out because we're kind of
investing a good amount of money into
this all right so we only managed to buy
one of the black plate bodies H we had
that offer there for ages so we only got
one uh but we did sell the rest of our
items pretty quickly um so the team
capes team Cape 9 they did crash to 129
so we we made 29k on it so whatever
that's still not too bad and um the full
Helms we sold for I guess about 10K
profit on each one that's 50k just from
the full Helms and yeah so we bought the
the play body for 150k we're going to
try to sell it for 200 not sure if
that's going to happen because you can
kind of see it's in a little bit of a
downward Trend so we might break even on
this maybe make 10K or something but
we'll try to put it in for 200 and hope
for the best yeah so 200 for that I
think the next item we're going to try
again is the mithil full Helms or
possibly the mythal play legs but man
they just made us so much money there's
just no reason not to do them and after
these items there's only a couple more
free playay items I can really try um so
yeah the miserable full Helms people are
um buying them for
21k let's see what buy
prices at 5K see look at that that's
like 15K right there you almost always
sell them for 20K or more so yeah we're
just going to try to buy 20 n 30 of them
why not I mean for each one we buy we
could potentially make 15K on that so
we'll put the my full Helms in and for
the last item here I think we're going
to just do another team Cape cuz why not
the team capes are working the trimmed
armor is working we'll slowly Branch out
into other items
but this is not going to last forever so
we might as well especially when people
are looking at my video so I might as
well take advantage of this while I can
um yeah so we're going to try the team c
one team c 1 had a pretty decent margin
on it so we're going to try to buy I
probably couple thousand of those might
get a tenth of that yeah so we'll put an
offer in for 260 here and we'll buy
about a thousand of them and I'm just
going to leave this in for a while so
I'll check back in a couple hours
probably all right right so everything
is sold um the black plate body we sold
for just a 10K profit so not too much on
that but we didn't lose any money uh the
myal full Helms we managed to buy
15 of them and we so we bought them all
for 76k and we sold them for 285k so
that's over 200k profit right there look
at that that's like more like 25k so
that was super easy and the team capes
we made about 20K on so not as much on
that but still I mean God those full
Helms are so good okay so the first item
we're going to try this time is going to
be different we're going to try the
mithil full Helm te I believe yeah yeah
so mythal fmt uh we're going to check
the margin here so we're going to buy it
for 10K and we're going to sell it
for I think somewhere around
2K y 2265 so that has like a 78k margin
on that so that's a great first item uh
so we're going to buy well I might as
well buy a ton of these CU we're only 2K
each all right so we end up buying
40 all right and so we're looking for a
second item here I think we're going to
go with one we've tried a couple times
the admin play legs I checked a couple
of the other wackier items and they
didn't really seem to have very good
margins on them so we're going to try
the adamant uh full Helm first um too
lazy to put the mar up enough to buy it
so I think we're just going to move on
to the adamant plate legs y so the
adamant plate legs uh we're going to try
buying for 30k let's see here yep so
they're buying for 28 pretty much
29k and uh we'll see what we can sell
them for 10K so that's a good margin
that's 20K right there uh so we're going
to buy probably 10 20 or 30 of
these let's let's have a look
what why' I do that all right we've been
looking for an item forever now so I
think we're just going to do the team
Cape 30 can't really find anything too
much better they seem to sell pretty
quickly though so this shouldn't be too
bad you can see all the items I've tried
there um yeah so let's try team cave 30
I think we bought them for somewhere
around the 500
Mark yeah 500 exactly actually
and yeah we'll sell them I think there
was two or 300 GP profit on here uh so
really not too bad actually that's
pretty good so that was worth the wait
actually so we'll put in an offer for
thousand or something of these and I
will check back when a couple of these
things have
bought okay so we sold um seven of the
Adent play legs for 25k each um so
that's a 15K profit on each one um we
ditched the team capes cuz they were
buying so slowly and we instead bought
some admin PL legs for just 6K each so
should we make a lot of money on
that and we are slowly selling these off
oh my God this taking forever um but we
are steadily making 2700 per sale so
that will
eventually um net us quite a bit of
money so on the plate legs we made about
105k when we sell all of these freaking
Mythril plate legs T um we will get
about
120k and um yep so for this um time
we're going to sell the adamant plate
legs that we did manage to buy uh we
just check the margin there quickly
looks like it's about 18K from six so
it's about 12K on that so that's another
healthy margin that we can take
advantage
of okay for our last item here we are
going to try uh the iron plate legs uh
so iron plate legs G now can see it says
it's actively traded for 300K which I
don't know if that's right um so we we
take it out but we're going to put in
for about the same but
99k and we're hoping to make let's say
maybe 30 or 40K off this item um we're
only going to buy one I believe or maybe
actually no we'll buy a couple um we'll
buy four and uh we'll see how this works
out all right so we have sold everything
and I think this where we're going to
tally up uh the items we have and just
call it the end of the episode um so we
sold all the admin plate legs for a 11k
GP profit per plate leg so that was 143k
there uh the iron plate legs got a
little scared and dumped them just for a
10K profit um still 40K and we're almost
done selling all these mythal play legs
te so one they the ones we've sold we
made about just over 100k on so still
very happy with all these flips so if we
take where we started the episode at uh
which was
946k we are at almost 2 mil we are at
1950 K plus 25k in items so we made over
a m this episode and probably the least
amount of flips and actual time like
this is probably recorded over 3 days so
a mill in 3 days is not that bad
considering I probably to play like an
hour a day or something maybe less even
I just check it I think about it a bit
but honestly honly when I'm logged in
probably only 50 minutes at a time and
this would be even shorter if I wasn't
recording everything so yeah the insane
progress this episode we are getting
very close to a bond uh so we probably
only be a couple more episodes and then
we're going to have to figure out what
we're going to do past then uh but yeah
thanks for tuning in guys uh if you
enjoyed it I would really appreciate it
if you left a comment a like or if you
want to see more just uh hit the
Subscribe button awesome I'll see you
guys next episode
no
[Music]